jacques higelin et se produit au théâtre
mogador près de l'opéra à paris jusqu'au
4 janvier
higelin comédiens vous l'avez vu dans
elle court elle court la banlieue ou
dans bébert et l'omnibus c'est là aussi
écrit des sketches
il a joué au théâtre avec romain
bouteille mais avant toute chose il
compose des chansons personnage hors du
commun du cabba pardon il pourrait avoir
selon certains spécialistes des variétés
un nom plus grand s'il le voulait
m
oui
je suis né dans un spasme le ventre de
ma mère a craché un noyau de jouissance
et j'ai jamais perdu le coût de sa dette
que l'aja 19 40
et aux 40
présentée depuis combien de temps
depuis que j'ai poussé
le premier depuis mes premiers âges de
dents
jacques higelin bien difficile de
définir l'homme et l'artiste un petit
goût pour la provocation mais surtout
une immense sincérité un besoin fou de
vivre et de communiquer avec les autres
il a été comédien il est avant tout l'un
des auteurs de chansons les plus doués
de sa génération
et cela même si un goût pour le voyage
pour la vie au large pour la vie en
marge la parfois éloignés des chemins du
succès je me sens comme un baladin mais
je me sens pas comme un objet
consommation c'est pour ça que je me
suis pas tellement occupé de ma carrière
je me suis occupée
de l'avis fans de ce que j'avais à faire
avec les autres
du plaisir aussi
et
vous étiez le père noël 1980 qu'est ce
que vous apportez riez tous genres aux
gens le temps
tandis way le temps c'est la première
des choses que j'aimerais apporter aux
gens
si jamais le pouvoir de leur apporter
quoi que ce soit c'est le temps
pour pouvoir respirer pouvoir souffler
pour avoir le temps de jouir de la vie
et de pensée un peu choses importantes
comme l'amour
oui l'amour ça tel que vous riez parce
que j'aime ça parce que ça m'intimide
aussi de parler plus ou moins des fois
mais pour ça il faut avoir le temps il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens sont
malheureux parce qu'ils sont toujours
stressés ils sont pressés comme des
citrons
et après l'échec c'est pal m
des viendra que dans la boîte aux
lettres des modèles
il ya des allumettes et bien que comme
un vol elle échappait de peu les yeux
et
ok rendez-vous à plus tard